[Music]
one day at a Dallas fuel practice
session during over watching season one
time we took a [ __ ] that kick-started
their stage for Cinderella Ron I swear
I'm not making this up Seagal told us
let me take you back in time real quick
Blizzard announced the overwash league
in 2016 and that was a really big deal
but there was a long wait involved see
the league didn't actually start until
2018
/ watch it sounds like you guys like
what you saw oh so what happened as is
often the case with eSports is that the
scene relied on third party tournaments
like the apex series in Korea where team
NV were crowned season 1 champions and a
historic win envious dashing towards a
trophy and man if they earned it
especially in this postseason wow what
an amazing story time who gets there
first but congratulations to NV it was
also during the apex era that Siegel
became a household name in the overwatch
community here's a guy who goes by the
name of Segal finishing up an interview
at a competition this week and check out
his cool handshake at the end ah
excellent man well thank you very much
for your time and we're going to send it
back to the desk right now he was a
beloved DPS player while he was on NRG
and with a massive community figure on
Twitch
[Music]
heading into season one of the overwatch
league team NV became the Dallas fuel
and with C go on board they were the
single most hyped Western roster
everyone expected the Korean teams to
run roughshod over the rest of the world
once the o WL began so the Dallas fuel
held the weight of the NA fan base on
their shoulders and well they kind of
crumbled beneath a Mickey the last man
standing on the point maybe if you aura
can get in there effect has the
dragonblade but can you get there in
time time ticking away and that is it
and they will take the series
three-and-oh only the even that first
tick to win the map and those are the
kills they're looking for that's gonna
be it london spitfire will take the 3-1
victory over dallas field i think that's
gonna be it it's just broken with the
primal rage and he's not going to be
enough
do you alright well win three to one the
Dallas knew limped to a three seven
finish in the first stage of the
inaugural season and after their rough
record Siegel was benched after that
time period
pretty much coaching / management lost
all faith of me is how I put it I don't
think I played in a scrim for probably
four weeks by that point I was just over
three weeks so transition had happened
they've moved on without me is the TLDR
rate the field did themselves one worse
and went to eight in stage two then
finished stage 3 with a horrendous 109
record the team was reeling and it was
clear that in order for the tides to
turn something massive needed to change
going into week ten we had this like
major issue where we were originally
bringing Teemo onto main tank and hoping
that he could adjust that role while we
tried to find a new main tank to fit the
position Teemo was getting really hard
on himself he wasn't really getting the
performances that he wanted he he didn't
have a quick fix to all the issues that
he was having and he was getting really
frustrated during season one of the
overwatch League dive was the way to
plug the dive meta game featured to dive
tanks and Winston and Deva paired with
agile and lethal DPS characters like
tracer and Genji which allowed your team
to ambush enemy supports and snowball
team fights jealous trying to push this
look back a km2 lake for as long as he
can here comes Mickey now they've got
the Nano boost on him and he's gonna
dive right in on the beach ooh there's a
kill for him gets hydration as well so
they managed to turn it around in many
ways deva was the linchpin of dive she
created space for her teammates stopped
enemy also her defense matrix and closed
out game ending wombo combo x' with her
oh knowledge and that's where Siegel's
journey back onto the starting roster
began in the three weeks plus I think
that I didn't play I think it was 24 or
25 days total
I didn't play a single scrim I was
spectating every diva player and I had
like this spreadsheet I was just writing
and taking notes every day on every day
of a player why they were good why they
sucked what they needed to improve on
this and that and what they did tima
brought up that he doesn't feel like he
can perform at Level II wanted to
perform it and initially thought he
could perform it we talked to prove with
the team and that's how we started to
make the change from team away from main
tank and then by that point I realized
that diva wasn't mechanically that
difficult I was strictly learning diva
and so I put in probably around 40 to 60
hours of diva on ladder one thing full
day during scram is time who had to take
a [ __ ] and that [ __ ] changed eagles
position with the team so we decided to
go okay so you girls here Mickey's here
how about we put Seagal on Devo cuz
you've been practicing diva eventually I
got my shot cuz Teemo attitude [ __ ] and
I did really well on the scrim
then we got to play New York and that
was the most important series because
they were starting to trial other diva
players and that was my opportunity to
fight for my spot having secured a spot
single master diva for stage 4 and
during the fourth and final stage of
season 1 the Dallas feel will play a
completely new team trying to get that
rally in there don't say Viet Lee no
hesitation oh the double Joe from Seagal
again when the stylish self-destruct
again with the massive plays in this
game you can revive the clay pigeons
Noah extravaganza right here apparently
a lot of people said it tank heavy metis
going to favor the fuel true they run
Mickey on the brick Itza they run Siegel
on the diva now the fruits of their
labor for having Siegel practice so much
off tank this season now it's coming
back as a boon to the fuel they finished
with a solid six and four putting them
in the top four of the overall league
standings and qualifying them for the
playoffs and of course the main
difference in their roster was Segal who
returned to the starting lineup as it
seems primary diva player during this
time he was by far the best diva player
in the entire league and was a force to
be reckoned with among the best players
the game had to offer but when the
state's for playoffs actually came
around there was still one obstacle left
and see those way maybe the greatest
obstacle the overwatch League had to
offer the New York Excelsior and New
York let them know that they'd have to
step up their game one more level if
they wanted to compete for the stage for
crown
trance nobody else is gonna die here for
New York Segal you're the last one
uncle's trying to float his way back
into the fight but it's not meant to be
a New York excels they're running away
with the text area hook going for the
mouth trying to fly his way back into
this fight but they will not make it in
time and a second map picked up for the
New York XL taking the lead in this best
of five series long as that bubble
survives they may be able to hang in
here just a little while longer trying
to get onto animo trying to remove that
healing on about tight spot it is Lee
the boys just long enough for a Dallas
fuel to find the victory keeps Dallas
school alive at the semi-final Justin
should be able to get back Beco maybe
touch he gets bashed away again no one
can touch Dallas fuel making it exciting
let's go to map number five seven but it
wasn't meant to be that storybook run
that started way back and that fateful
scrim was cut short by New York Mickey
will be the one to contest finally
somebody here for the Dallas jewel that
allows for time to get out on to the
point as well Harry hook trying to play
the angle just try to stay alive trying
to get the heal but that kill
self-destruct talk and it's New Yor
Excel winning 3-2 in the end advancing
to the finals over Dallas there was
something different about Dallas in
stage four though and when it mattered
most in that last series Segal led the
team in kill Segoe retired from the
overwatch league to become a full-time
streamer shortly after that loss and the
Dallas field didn't compete the season
one playoffs but that stage for that
small pocket of overwatch history was
incredible for him and the Dallas fuel
that season Segal showed us that with
hard work and dedication even the
wildest dreams can come true and that
one trip to the bathroom can change
everything thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]